[Musique]
concrètement on parle d'entreprises en
difficulté dans le cadre justement dès
lors qu'il ya des échéances financières
qui peinent à être honoré nous
rencontrons aujourd'hui beaucoup de
défaillances justement de paiement
certaine échéance
concrètement ce que nous essayons
d'avoir c'est justement une prévention
en faveur des entreprises pour éviter
que des sociétés de notre côté rite war
soit dans ce cadre justement de
difficultés d'entreprises
l'objectif c'est de trouver des
solutions en amont de ces problématiques
de trésorerie
[Musique]
la première chose à faire c'est de se
poser les bonnes questions et de se
faire accompagner
l'objectif c'est de ne pas être seule
est toujours d'aller chercher en fait
les compétences là où nous avons des
expertises 1 h 30 de commerce nous avons
mis en place un système de réseau avec
un vrai partenariat de tutorat on
appelle le roseau réseau opérationnel de
soutien et d'appui d'urgence qui va être
un outil fort d'accompagnement pour ces
entreprises qu'on appelle en difficulté
ou en phase de rebond
[Musique]
on parle effectivement d' état de
cessation de paiement de liquidation
judiciaire demande haddock
toutes ces préventions en fait qu'ils
sont là pour protéger le chef
d'entreprise ne sont pas considérés de
façon isolée
il vaut mieux aller au centre de
prévention des entreprises qui s'appelle
le csb que nous hébergeons assez 6,78
qui va au mieux conseillés justement par
biais d'un ancien juge du tribunal de
commerce d'un expert comptable en
activité et d'un avocat orienter le chef
d'entreprise vers la meilleure des
solutions